Elles peuvent construire en autonomie des structures suspendues.
Elles ont appris à porter des charges,
à gérer les perturbations,
et, de manière générale, à interagir avec le monde physique.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous montrer quelques-uns de nos projets en cours.
Notre but est de repousser les limites du possible des vols autonomes.
Pour qu'un système fonctionne de manière autonome,
il doit connaître collectivement, la localisation de chaque objet volant
qui constitue son essaim.
Dans notre labo à ETH Zurich,
nous utilisons des caméras externes pour localiser les objets.
Ça nous permet de concentrer nos efforts
sur le développement rapide de tâches très dynamiques.
Les démos d'aujourd'hui sont basées sur une nouvelle technique de localisation
développée par Verity Studios, une spin-off du labo.
Il n'y a pas de caméra externe.
Chaque engin volant détermine sa localisation dans l'espace
avec des capteurs embarqués,
et un ordinateur embarqué qui détermine les actions à prendre.
Les seules commandes externes sont les plus sensibles :
« décoller » et « atterrir ».
Voici ce qu'on appelle une « aile VTOL ».
C'est un avion qui veut le beurre, et l'argent du beurre.
Comme tout aéronef à voilure fixe, il est très efficace pour voler,
bien meilleur que les hélicoptères.
Contrairement aux avions à voilure fixe,
il peut voler verticalement.
C'est particulièrement intéressant au décollage et à l'atterrissage,
et offre une grande flexibilité.
Hélas, il y a un revers de la médaille.
Une des contraintes des ailes VTOL
est sa sensibilité aux perturbations comme les rafales de vent.
Nous développons des architectures et algorithmes nouveaux
pour résoudre ces contraintes.
Le principe est que l'aéronef puisse récupérer sa stabilité,
quelle que soit la situation,
et, avec l'expérience, qu'il améliore ses performances.
(Applaudissements)
Bon.
Dans nos recherches,
nous nous posons souvent des questions fondamentales abstraites
pour aller au cœur du sujet.
Une de ces question est la suivante :
quel est le nombre minimum de composants animés nécessaires pour contrôler un vol ?
Il y a plusieurs raisons pratiques derrière ses questions.
Prenez les hélicoptères.
On les affectionne parce qu'ils sont constitués de 1000 composants mobiles,
qui se liguent toutes pour vous blesser.
Or, des pilotes expérimentés ont pu, il y a des dizaines d'années de ça,
faire voler à distance des aéronefs équipés de deux composants animés :
une hélice et un gouvernail.
Nous venons de découvrir qu'une seule pièce mobile suffit.
Voici un Mono Spinner,
l'objet volant télécommandé le plus simple mécaniquement parlant,
sorti du berceau il y a quelques mois.
Il n'a qu'un seul composant animé : une hélice.
Il n'y a ni volets, ni charnières, ni ailerons.
Aucun vérin, aucune surface de contrôle.
Il n'y a qu'une simple hélice.
Quoique mécaniquement simple,
le cerveau électronique fonctionne à plein régime,
pour lui permettre de voler de manière stable,
et de se mouvoir librement.
Il n'est pas encore muni des algorithmes sophistiqués de l'aile VTOL.
Ce qui signifie que pour qu'il vole,
on doit le lancer d'une manière très précise.
La probabilité que j'y arrive devant vous est très faible.
Je préfère donc vous en montrer une vidéo, filmée hier soir.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Le monospinner représente la frugalité.
Voici maintenant son opposé, l'Omni Copter, composé de huit hélices.
C'est un exercice dans l'excès.
Que faire de tous ces excédents ?
Vous le constatez, il est très symétrique.
La conséquence est son ambivalence par rapport à l'orientation.
Ça lui confère des capacités de vol extraordinaires
n'importe où dans l'espace,
sans notion d'avant ou d'arrière, ou de rotation sur lui-même.
Il a ses propres difficultés,
principalement liées à l'interaction des courants
provoqués par ses huit hélices.
Une partie de tout ça peut être modélisée. Le reste est appris en volant.
Regardons ensemble.
(Applaudissements)
Comme les drones vont faire partie de notre vie quotidienne,
ils devront être extrêmement sûrs et fiables.
Cette machine, là-bas,
est constituée de deux objets volants, équipés de deux hélices.
Celui-ci tourne dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre.
Celui-là, dans le sens contraire.
Quand on les couple,
ils se comportent comme un quadricoptère à haute performance.
Si un problème survient,
un rotor ou une hélice en panne, l'électronique ou une batterie qui lâche,
il peut continuer de rester en vol, quoique ses performances se dégradent.
Je vais vous montrer ça en désactivant une moitié.
(Applaudissements)
La dernière démonstration explore les essaims synthétiques.
Un grand nombre d'entités autonomes et coordonnées
ouvre des perspectives nouvelles à l'expression artistique.
Nous avons acheté des micro quadrimoteurs,
qui sont moins lourds qu'une tranche de pain.
Nous les avons équipés de notre technologie,
et d'algorithmes dédiés.
Leur nombre peut être illimité
parce que chaque unité connaît sa localisation dans l'espace,
et s'auto-contrôle.
(Applaudissements)
J'espère que ces démonstrations vont vous inciter à imaginer
des nouveaux rôles révolutionnaires pour les objets volants.
Celui-ci, qui est ultra-sûr,
aspire à fournir un éclairage indirect à Broadway.
(Rires)
En fait, c'est très difficile de prédire
l'impact qu'aura cette technologie naissante.
Pour nous, la satisfaction émerge du voyage et du processus créatif.
Ça nous rappelle combien notre univers est merveilleux et magique,
qu'il pousse les être créatifs à le ciseler de manière si spectaculaire.
Que cette technologie recèle un potentiel économique et commercial extraordinaire
n'est que la cerise sur le gateau.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)